what do you understand about the world
what do you understand about it and what
would you say to your
20 year old self that just is about to
win the title
i always think about the world now that
i'm one with everything
that we all we're involved with
everything i'm involved with the [ __ ]
i'm involved with the bugs involved with
the ants the butterflies
the cats the dogs i'm wanted with
everything the cars
smoke everything i'm one with it all
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot boxing
i'm evan britton and i'm mike tyson dude
we got a great guest today
we got a guest who
i'm a big fan of i heard this guy on a
podcast
a couple years ago i think and his
name's lewis howes
great to have you here brother thanks
for watching what do you call yourself
are you you're sort of like this new age
philosopher
you're a young great thinker i
appreciate that guy you are brother
yes he's written a book sorry let me
give you a little more intro
he's written a book about new york times
best-selling author
this book in particular that's on my
mind which is very pertinent to our show
is called the mask of masculinity wow
and i think we got a lot to talk about
there it was was a um
a european thing it was a phil i'm not a
philosopher but i think
i'm a [ __ ] um therapist and
he did um the same thing with the mask
of sanity
got his but with about everyday people
we we're not who we
appear to be yeah we put on masks yeah
we put on this uh projection to try to
fit in or try to make people like us or
try to
please people or win people over and we
were just talking about this before that
you played in the nfl for a number of
years
and you had an identity a mass that you
wore to fit in
to be that player right to play the role
of
linemen big tough guy whatever maybe the
tough guy because everybody
i don't care who was the gangster
anymore they respected a tough guy
that's it yeah that was your life
growing up
they respected you because you didn't
back down yeah i was bullied when i was
a kid
and i said wow if i was like these guys
that were bullying me
nobody would [ __ ] with me right and you
became the ultimate
bully of the world by destroying
everyone and here's the thing these
masks that men wear
they serve a purpose because it helps us
get a result in our life
you know i wore the athlete mask which
was
i will do whatever it takes to win at
all costs i will
freaking destroy people on the field i
will train my butt off i'll hurt myself
i won't sleep i'll freaking do whatever
to get bigger faster stronger at all
costs so that i can achieve my goal and
here's the crazy thing these masks work
because you were in the nfl you became
the ultimate
bully and were the greatest fighter of
all time
but here's what doesn't work we are left
with this sense of like
this prison inside right we might
achieve success on the outside but then
we are prisoners and we are unfulfilled
on the inside
and we don't know what inner peace is so
the masks hold us back from inner peace
and we take that out and i love when
people close everyone a family our
children
everyone everyone suffers around us when
we wear masks absolutely
so yeah so that's why i wrote the book
because i was i was achieving at every
level i was making millions i was
you know playing professional football i
was accomplishing things but i was
suffering inside i knew if i didn't
change i couldn't have a family like my
kids wouldn't respect me
i was just on that verge when my kids
were once not respecting me no more
really was right there the clip isn't so
[ __ ] frightening
wow how did it feel when they weren't
respect when they started to not respect
you
i don't know i felt like dying i wanted
to kill them really yeah
that's all i have in my children they
didn't respect me i didn't want to live
anymore
wow how old were you then um
39 wow yeah
so that was a big wake-up call for you
that was something that's pretty big
yeah
so how did you start to shift to get
their respect again
because it was 40 years of conditioning
it was so [ __ ] it was so hard
you just said um you have to be
available you have to come to work you
have to show up
you know you have gratitude
you have a lot of gratitude in your life
right now oh
i've been beaten in submission so i have
a lot of gratitude yeah yeah
what was the biggest beat down you've
ever had whether it be
physically or emotionally or spiritually
i lost my four-year-old daughter she
accidentally killed herself by accident
oh man she jumped on a treadmill
she's not working and she had hurt wow
so um after that i didn't know what to
do
you know you didn't know what to do
how did you recover from that and i have
it
i just know in order to make a happy
have to do good things and be positive
yeah wow
were you did you ever think positive
before that moment or when you were
fighting as well or was it always
negative
no it was always about me so i believe
about my dick
[ __ ] everybody else yeah
you know i would give people money and
stuff you know you know i was capable of
being kind to people nice to people
but it didn't matter it's one of what i
wanted and that's all that mattered
right why do you think we care so much
about those things about like what we
win or what we get why do you think
men in general because um listen this is
what happens
um us as little kids especially
boys what we hear we think of great men
all the time
we think of people that we heard you
hear about that guy knocked that guy off
the crown the corner what was his name
again
we always hear legend we hear about jim
brown we hear about bruce lee we hear
about all these guys
and we want to know how this badass guy
is telling me about these guys i'm
scared of this guy's telling me about
these [ __ ] guys
yeah so i want to be like these guys for
guys like this could be afraid of me or
respect me or something you know and
it's ancient
yeah it's very ancient night slaying the
dragon yeah
you know going out on a hunt jim brown
the football player yeah
i didn't know he was a football player
from the streets i thought he was a
badass kicking motherfucker's asses in
the street i didn't know he was a
football player i thought he was a
badass
[ __ ] i had no idea what the
football played so i got older
yeah that's awesome why do you think you
wanted to
respect was the thing you wanted the
most from people because they bullied me
all the time everybody picked on me
why do you think they picked on you i
don't know got nobody to protect me
uh i know um you know
there's some people in the neighborhood
they got very intimidating families they
may have 20 kids in the family
you're not going to mess with them
they're very aggressive yeah cousins and
their brothers and everything they're
very aggressive
so we don't bother those guys yeah
because they got a family to get behind
you yeah
you had no family to get by your family
they didn't know dang
what do you think about that louis why
do people
what is the thing about bullying is it
that we're programmed
to gain superiority over others
i think bullies are very insecure and
they want to feel
they want to feel in power and they
they're actually powerless
and so they create scenarios to have
power over other people to feel like
they're in control
you know they're very insecure i think
we've all bullied at some time
whether it be one person or a group of
people or you know in a relationship i
think we've all
our fault of it uh because we want to
feel a sense of control
or power or certainty and that lack of
certainty you know when you're
12 years old growing up you have no
certainty it's like who am i what am i
doing you know we have no certainties
because the fact is as we talk really
look at this as we talk
evan when you think about it this is
these quick few questions
um check it out who are you yeah no one
knows when you're 12. yeah
wherever you came from yeah what is your
purpose
why are you breathing why do you look
the way you do yeah
who's the first you that that you know
you have to meet your existence the
first one probably a million years ago
10 million years ago
who is he what did he look like was he
black or the asian crazy right you don't
even know
who the first us was why do you think
you're here mike
excuse me why do you think you're here
why do i think i'm here
to understand the world yeah before i
die
to be lucky to understand it and be
conscious of it before i die
what do you understand about the world
so far in your or your 50 how do you
know
how what do you understand about it and
what do you understand about it and what
would you say to your 20 year old self
that
just is about to win the title i was
thinking about the world now that
i'm one with everything that we all
we're involved with everything i'm
involved with the [ __ ]
i'm involved with the bugs i'm involved
with the ants the butterflies
the cats the dogs i'm wanted with
everything the clouds the sewage
everything the cars smoke everything i'm
one with it all
what did you think back then excuse me
what did you think
uh your understanding of the world was
when you were 20. when i was 20
what was your viewpoint of the world um
i had no viewpoint
the only thing i knew was um these guys
were great champions and i wanted to be
like
yeah yeah it's interesting i remember
when i was a kid when i was five
i would watch um college football with
my dad on tv i would watch ohio state
buckeyes i'm from ohio
a small town in ohio called delaware
ohio and i would see the all-americans
on tv and my dad would get so excited
about the all-american football players
at ohio state
and i was like because my dad talked
about it that's what i wanted to be
and so my whole life became how do i
become an all-american athlete
and that was the only thing i cared
about and then when it was over i was
like well who am i and what do i do with
my life just kind of like when you
retired from football
this identity dick buckets all those
guys had to deal with that
yeah imagine being so immortal in the on
the on
on the football field and then that
stops stops and then you live in the
past
constantly you can't help it how could
you not help it
yeah tell me that especially in the 50s
and stuff when people weren't elevated
on
after we're done with this we haven't
saved up we're [ __ ] that's crude
if we didn't save up after this career
we're [ __ ] we're in the gutter again
care black white chinese unless somebody
somebody's such a big fan they have rich
guys
i love them when i play and they gave
you a job that's what happened about
those guys
they became salesmen for the big
corporation because guys loved them when
they were playing
but then the glory was over though you
know it's the ultimate endeavor to have
to
reinvent yourself and everyone has to do
that
all the time all the time every couple
years it's almost like you have to all
the time
shedding skins letting go transforming
your
mindset and your thoughts yeah what was
it like for you
when you had to reinvent through
financially because you went i think you
went bankrupt once or twice or
you know how did you rebuild and
reinvent
from a place of man i just had
everything and now i
i lost it from whatever i had everything
and next thing you know i'm 60 million
in debt
now you oh now you owe everything dude
oh everything now oh [ __ ]
millionaires how'd you get out of that
listen right for some reason they
thought i was trying to get out get out
and get a deal to get out of this um
bankruptcy they thought i was gonna
still fight i had no intention of
fighting they said yeah you got to fight
so they kept thinking i was gonna fight
and they wouldn't give me deals and so i
just
this way i just kept paying a little bit
at a time make some money i could pay
them
and then next thing you know i would owe
them money for so long
they would say hey you owe this for so
long so we go to decline you own us this
is
because you're not paying us we owed it
for so long tonight oh it's five million
we're gonna take seven to five million
off and so that's how i was getting down
and so they said all right we gotta take
this off too
and i wind up owning them two million
dollars and i paid that and it was over
done oh nice wow
wow but you haven't paid the seven
months if you don't pay this in seven
months you're gonna take 20 million off
or something like
never pay how could they do are them
supposed to take everything that was
living in madness they supposed to took
all that [ __ ]
how did that happen interesting i was
thinking i thought i'm keeping all this
[ __ ] out of not coming to take this
stuff
interesting yeah they never came to take
anything
what do you think the moment what was
the at cars and stuff i couldn't ride
them because i couldn't
have money to put gas in them that rolls
royce and they can't ride them
just sitting there yeah yeah that's so
crazy mike
crazy was there a moment in your life uh
was it maybe the bankruptcy
or when your daughter died or when you
lost respect with your
your kids was there a moment when like
things really started to shift in your
mind to say
okay i need to figure this stuff out i
need to really
i didn't have the slightest idea i got
involved with this woman who's now my
wife right
and she just kept saying everything's
gonna be all right we're gonna write a
show we're gonna produce um television
shows and movies
and this is gonna be over i'm looking at
her and i'm still strung on drugs
and i'm looking at others just to lose
you know
and the next thing you know we were
talking about we went and saw chad's
parliamentary bronx tale but we saw it
on stage
it was magnificent it was um
it was so quiet you could hear a mouse
piss on cotton he was so captivating
do you know i mean this guy was so
captivating chad's palmetto was so
captivated everybody was so quiet
and i said baby i want to do that baby i
do that before like when i go to europe
people ask me questions and i answer the
question but this time i just want to
ask the question i didn't do it
you know i mean um theatrically like mr
commentary and um she was writing the
script
and we were rehearsing she was writing
the script we didn't know how we would
ever do
and then a friend of mine was at the gym
where i work at
and the guy was like don't mike tyson
work and he said yeah he said if you
ever see him give him a call i want to
do a show with him
whoa come out of nowhere manifesting
that
it came out the universe a week later so
should we
so we we called the guy it took my wife
i think six weeks to write the show
wow her first show ever we did the show
standing room over knockout blast all
over the
world knocked the country we did it on
broadway for three weeks first show
in vegas yeah on vegas was knocked
everybody out everybody came down always
so one of spike lee's assistants came
and saw the show and said spike i think
we should get into this and then spikes
would want to go to broadway i was in
poland he called me so you want to go to
broadway we went to broadway
listen we went to bro everybody came all
the broadway shows and actresses and the
actors came
stevie won everybody came all the actors
who we did on the pen year
here in california all the people from
the sets came
all the actors and that just everybody
was so awesome
i couldn't believe we could ever do
something like that be on that level
where they would come watch us
do something other than a fight
something i'm not going to get hurt
doing i did that
you know i said well i'm performing
these guys are coming and they're
enjoying it
i've heard you talk about this a lot but
how did you feel being so honest
and vulnerable about your experiences
was that the first time you had really
done that i mean
yeah kind of but listen um it was it was
embarrassing at first but
the people knew all this people that was
all they knew they saw what happened in
the paper they read the paper they saw
what happened they saw what happened
people complained about it on television
so i couldn't everybody knew what
happened so i had to be very honest you
did the
you were the eight mile move it was like
the end of eight mile we're just like
here's everything i did you know i'm
gonna say it all yeah yeah yeah
everybody knew it but they just never
heard me say it but they all know
me what yeah everybody there wasn't no
secrets i i watched i didn't watch it
live i wanted to when it was on broadway
but i remember watching it on
on was it hbo or something like that
and my friend saw it and he's like you
have to watch this he goes
it's one of the greatest performances
i've ever seen and i was like no
freaking way mike tyson doing a one-man
show i was like there's no way
and i turned this thing on and i'm not
just saying this because you're here i
turned this thing on i was like wow
you're an incredible
storyteller and an incredible performer
you know obviously you're a great
performer as an athlete but you
transitioned
and i don't think anyone saw it coming
that you had that capacity and
capability to
captivate an audience whether it be live
or tv audience
and you did an incredible job man i mean
thank you it was inspiring
listen um evan my wife it was supposed
to be a gritty hardcore show
a hardcore guy that came home it came
out like a car
my heart tough yeah you know i'm talking
about not having a father the people
broke our left so i ran back to the
street i said
what's going on what's happening why
they laughing why they laughing he said
it's going to keep it going keep it
going
it's good keep it going laughing keep it
going what was the biggest lesson you
learned about yourself
after that whole experience had finished
um
that shouldn't be too hard on myself you
know that should be i should be more
appreciative of what they have
accomplished from where i've came from
that's amazing are you usually hard on
yourself absolutely
why i don't know that's all i've ever
known because if i made mistakes um
i got harshly you know me verbally yeah
yeah you heard some bad stuff before
[ __ ] up yeah there's some stuff you
didn't want to hear
so you get yourself you get yourself
numb to that by calling yourself that
all the time
i'm a loser i suck the [ __ ] are you
stupid [ __ ]
you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] how could you do
that
yeah what do you what do you say to
yourself now
what what's the conversation you say to
yourself oh i love
myself i love my kids isn't your kids
office aren't you very lucky
that you have your wife where would you
be without her wow
it's beautiful man it's unbelievable
yeah i mean if mike tyson can transform
yeah you know what i mean as a as a
example of a man who's gone through a
lot of trauma
life prepares you life prepares you for
everything
prepares you for doing 100 years in jail
prepares you for
getting ready to go to the electric
chair prepares you for death
you know i mean when um when life is
enduring with you
when you're enduring with life and
you're making the age limits going to
your 50s your
60s yeah then you're making it up there
you're prepared all your friends are no
longer around most of your family mom
not around what the [ __ ] am i doing here
then we go wow you know
what's the thing that's prepared you uh
the most what experience that you've
gone through
uh do you think has prepared you the
most for where you're at now
yes i'm dropping my ego and when i think
my life would be
disastrous and i never took the toes i
took this um ancient medicine the toad
right and um it changed my whole
perspective on how i look at life and
how i look at people and how i talk to
people
wow do you know about the toad no
wow why don't you educate well educating
that's gonna be very interesting
awesome guy thank you so you know you
know about
ayahuasca of course yeah yeah so the
active ingredient in there is dmt yep
so the toad from its venom which they
extract
and then dry it over a certain period of
time it crystallizes it contains
five meodmt which
from the way i understand it is dmt with
an extra
methyl oxy group attached to it which
makes it
like super steroided like so it's super
charged
to your brain so it crosses the
blood-brain barrier faster wow
and so you know it does you vaporize it
and it does very much the same things as
dmt but it's
it's it's really the top of the pyramid
as far as anthogenic
substances wow and so you know people
are
cured of depression and addiction and
you know are released of
trauma and pain right yeah um and so
mike so you did it i had a very
transformational few times and um
listen if you take this um medicine
um
it's a possibility you may feel like god
wow
and then you may have a small encounter
with god and say oh god please forgive
me
i'm sorry is that what happened for you
yeah
what was the encounter like
i felt the pain of everybody i ever
heard before wow
that sounds pain that feels that's fine
god please lord i'm sorry
this is crazy you felt the pain of
everyone you hurt how many people do you
think you've hurt oh
man hundreds thousands tens of thousands
it's so amazing that pain that you could
feel it was i had nobody was nothing
i just existed wow you know you could
just feel everything
you feel and you said you didn't say
it's like being dead
you're vulnerable as hell there's no ego
you're afraid of it naked yeah
yeah just please don't hurt me i'm sorry
i'm sorry
please oh god please wow you know you
don't even see nobody
you're scared you just to feel yourself
so you're scared i'm sorry please
it's just i don't understand it and i've
never been the same since i did it
wow i only i don't think about hurting
people i don't think about loving people
you still
just don't want to do that stuff anymore
wow you know i've never been the same
since that you when
my in my um time in life i'm talking a
little faster my time on life
i thought i seen it all i thought i'd
been everywhere i think i [ __ ]
everybody drink everybody smoked it
i did it all and i realized i don't know
nothing and i'm nobody
wow i don't know anything
i don't know where i came from
i don't know my real name i mean
somebody named me mike
i don't know the [ __ ] i am huh i'm just
here
wow when when did you take this
nine months ago it was the first time i
did it recently not too long ago but
the first time in october wow yeah
it's been pretty amazing to be on this
ride with mike and
it's just crazy amount
of wisdom and insight
that comes from spending time with this
guy and i always used guard as the way
it used to be
in and i was never really up i knew of
god but i always i didn't i was
it was always it wasn't bigger than me
you were the you were bigger than god
yeah you were god yeah yeah my [ __ ]
sick head and then you realize that you
have to get on your knees you don't know
what his name is but you know you have
to worship
wow you know that's the taking the toll
yeah yeah
once you've been humbled a certain
amount of times then you're like okay
i'm not god anymore
right listen listen i'll tell you about
that ego
even though you're humble you stop he's
still there don't let him look at the
[ __ ] i might look around look at the
[ __ ] reflections and wow i'm handsome
it'll come the ego is a [ __ ]
once you take the toll you know he ain't
[ __ ]
yeah how do you let go of ego and how do
you how
what advice would you give to men who
are so ego driven
what would you say to them on how to
like let it go when they're so attached
to it
listen let me tell you something about
the ego from my experience
my i'm nothing but just a junkyard got a
kid right but my bad had nothing
i had nothing this this old italian man
gave me an ego
right and he gave me everything i wanted
the ego gave me everything i ever wanted
and more
but it took so much more in return what
did it take
took everything wow took
everything been in prison took
everything family love
yeah well you don't care animal you're
almost an animal wow
you know oh i never want to go there
again
wow man why you want to live like an
animal when you can't say give it up hey
i don't want to do it no more i love you
wow it's amazing crazy
it's awesome what's what's the thing the
lesson you have still yet to learn
for yourself to to get to that next
level that you want to be at is there a
lesson or is there a challenge that
you're struggling with a question inside
that still keeps you from more love more
fulfillment
impact what is that um why me
who the [ __ ] am i why why do millions of
people know me
and think of me in nice ways to why me
why'd i have to meet this guy he had
nothing he has died broken but how did
he give me the tricks that he had
to give me what i want i wanna you know
why me why did
how did he know i was the guy for this
job wow
i never had a boxing glove all my life i
never thought about sports never played
sports about how did he know i was the
guy
the universe yeah how did this [ __ ]
guy know
that blows me away this guy knows
crazy what do you think the world needs
more of right now
what is it what's it missing
um listen i don't know i can't say i
know i i can only say love
kindness um passion
patience you know among each other look
at each other as
equals you know everyone can
succeed in one particular way we can all
put
we all succeed if we work together in
any way
so true you know anyway no one wins
unless we all win
exactly and the conduct of one is the
faith of us
all and there's billions of stuff on it
the conduct of one is the fate of us
all say that one more time the conduct
of one the conduct of
one of us is the faith of all of us
what does that mean for you what does
that mean to you that we all have to be
in sync with one another
one guy robs the store and murders some
people that's the fate of all of us
one guy kills a guy because he's a
different color or a different religion
that's the fate of all of us
it's a powerful [ __ ] is he always this
this yeah insightful
yeah he is man i mean and that's just
really
to me why i think i've connected with
mike so much
is you know through my career in the nfl
and coming out of it
this dissolution of ego that's taken
place for me over the last four and a
half years
you know ego is just it crushes you
really at the end of the day
because that's the thing that ties you
into all of your desires and ideas about
who you are and what you're supposed to
be in this
manufactured realm and it chases
everybody that loves you away
exactly you only have [ __ ]
[ __ ] around you
it's never enough the eagle can never
have nobody you love around you it won't
work
why is that if somebody loves you and
your ego's [ __ ]
acting up and it's controlling you you
can't have you push them away yeah yeah
you [ __ ] sh you slammed them away
how much they try to love you you're
just like you can't do it you can't do
it won't work
because you're never satisfied never
filled that hole is never
full you know not enough women not
enough cars
not enough money not accomplishments
press not enough [ __ ] consumption
there's not enough to just consume and
feed that thing feed that beast and that
kind of
sickness if you can't have it all you
rather have nothing
because it's not enough it's not it's
not it's not all of it man they have
nothing is that what happened to you
i can't have everyone everything every
girl every drug every
day every movie if i can't have every
one of them all of them
i'd rather have nothing really yeah how
many how many women do you think you've
been with
i don't know not i'm not proud of it
though yeah that's stuff that i'm proud
of
yeah i don't even know why i did it yeah
i don't know what was the purpose of it
to try to fulfill something that we were
missing
no it was listen um i wanted those women
to love me
why because i didn't love myself wow
did you let them love you no [ __ ] way
how can i
love myself i gotta let them love me my
love was to make me [ __ ]
right or to tell me i was great to tell
me that was the best [ __ ] you ever had
that was my ego
yeah you know i mean that was my
fulfillment
i would pay you about your [ __ ] house
a car i'm the best all right
wow
what's uh how long have you been
together with your wife 10 no well more
than 10 were married 10 years
what's the greatest lesson she's taught
you in the last 10 years
then i don't own her did you used to
feel like you owned
the relationship i owned everything that
was in my presence wow
you're around me you're just a [ __ ]
worker i own you [ __ ]
you'll be accepting anything from you i
own you
you owe me i own you yeah yeah so when
did she
say you don't own me what what was that
like when she confronted you and said
hey you don't own me
listen let me tell you have you ever
been married no i've never been married
let me tell you something even
i'm telling marriage is something like
it's like a roller coaster right
yeah and it's really scary because the
roller coaster goes
up and it gets to the top and it's
making a lot of [ __ ] noise and that's
the beginning
we make a lot of noise about being in
love and then we get to the top
and then we come down fast and um
you can't grow you can't um you can't
learn this stuff you got to grow with
this stuff
yeah you got to go through it you can't
get ready for this you can't prepare for
this
you know what i mean you're going to
find out you and this person really care
about each other love is out of the
question that we're married
[ __ ] love now talk about how determined
you are to make this work for the
betterment of your children your name
god you know what i mean how tough are
you now you're a tough guy i won't see
how tough you are
you beat up a lot of people let's see
how tough you are with this
wow you know i mean this this is for god
let's see how tough you did this for
money [ __ ]
to see what you could do for god
what's the greatest awesome what's the
thing you love about her the most now
right now that she puts up with me let
me follow you i can't blast the bigger
can you believe we're still married
ten years yeah wow and then i ran into
the toad
wow oh man
toad life toad live up in here
toad life you really have to cultivate a
marriage man after work you've been
married yeah you're married right now
you got a two kids you said or
one kid like a two-year-old
seven-year-old seven-year-old wow once
you reach that's about what you
understand hey
we have to watch we have to take care of
ourselves we have to make sure our side
of the street is clean i
can't worry about her side of this yeah
i gotta make sure my side of the street
is clean that's a kid
give me absolutely i'm i'm not married
i've never been married uh but give me
the
the keys to getting into a marriage
that's happy and staying in a happy one
give me
your top three each i want to hear don't
take anything
personal never personal if she says
things how do you not take it personal
but it's wrong it takes a lot of
practice
but it's not wrong because no it's
triggered when they're attacking you you
know we have triggers from other
relationships and other lives
yeah they hit those triggers and we
blame them for the for the trouble that
everybody else calls us
because they press those buttons put
that pain back up so how do you not take
it personally when they're like
you mother it takes a lot of practice
you learn nothing okay
yeah and you say anytime i love you it
doesn't just happen that disarms them
yeah yeah okay always coming back to i
love you
i love you please i love you remember
how much you love them
and remind yourself of it and for me
it's
it's about taking the energy that i
bring into life because we can
take our families for granted yes you
know and we fall into
just autopilot uh you know programmed
mechanisms with our family especially
with an intimate
relationship and so over that time like
what mike was saying when that
love or that lusty super
hot sex time wears off because it's
going to
it will because we are as human beings
we are chemically programmed into that
especially men you know you are
biologically evolutionarily
programmed to procreate and spread your
seed you know
so this is something that we have to
battle or at least
learn how to hone and control
and it's important this is what i found
out too because you remember you said it
comes a time when you still want to do
it no more
you say yeah mr cool but you still like
to do but it's not like it used to be
that's because god prepares you do you
know i mean sometimes when you're
younger it has to go
you know and when you get older it's not
that important
yes it's not going to care as much
that's why god made it feel good
yeah because even when you're older now
it's not that point but it still feels
good i feel like feeling good right now
yeah you know so you have to come home
and you have to create
that romance and that love again
you know because that's why i remember
she would lose [ __ ] she'd pick something
up you know
why are you not being this way are you
with somebody else this way women pick
things up they're very sensitive pick up
the
you have to be um consistent the same
thing all the time all the time
stop one time or something they pick up
something consistency with women i
remember i learned that late to be
consistent
you have to be consistent consistent
never change your colors
wow they would pick that up quick that's
the first thing they picked one day you
changed
one thing well that's why communication
second she picks it and they're
different than we are
communication you see a whole bunch of
people in here and my wife was in here
we're all talking my wife remember here
only my voice everybody's talking she
remember everything i said
everybody's talking but she's going to
hear my voice that's how women are they
get
they get tuned in to your voice
everything about you your
characteristics
they want to know you they want to be
the puppet master that's not
they just want to know what is they
don't want to do the problem that they
want to know every move you make yeah
wow yes
and communication yeah communication
that's the third for sure communication
don't take things personally yeah and
we're just
remember how much you love them yeah
listen
please communicate because something
that happened six months ago and you
won't know until the outbursts come out
and you get what the hell happened
that's six months ago what always
communicate is everything okay baby
sure nothing's on your mind you don't
want to talk about anything every day
yeah
oh i've learned that late i started
doing that recently like
a year ago and i'm like [ __ ] yeah that's
pretty new for me wow
communication is just that's a constant
practice evan my whole life once i've
been married
all i did was throw money at my problems
yeah buy a house buy a mother house
buy some cars you know get away i can't
[ __ ] deal with no
children [ __ ] today yeah i don't want to
hear what the teacher said today
yeah [ __ ] the teacher it's not that's
not what your your
your partner wants to wants from you
they want you to listen and be
a partner yes yeah yeah they want to
know how the money's building they want
to know everything
you know what i mean and then when you
realize you don't have the money like
you used to have and you
throw those the money the problem you
have to deal now now you deal with the
problem
dealing with the problems that's
emotional i really almost died and deal
with the problem i wish i had something
to throw away she had some money i could
give a lawyer to deal with the problem
i definitely confronted that coming out
of the nfl
oh with my wife yeah
you're not just at a job all day
absolutely remember one day i was in the
city i said
why is it that men and women have to be
married why is it that we look for a
mate
and i tell you a man needs a woman to
make sure that he's a man
because she'll make sure that we're
america should test us and try us
and push us to the extent until they see
us yeah
breaking point yeah you know yeah
absolutely
by being a man you have to control
yourself and that's what they teach is
once you control yourself you control
your feelings with a woman
she said she i don't want to say submit
but she understand i can't get to him
don't you control your feelings because
we don't have the emotional intelligence
to control our feelings with the women
because in our mind i'm a macho man we
want to react
oh she bitching she making us look like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] she said that no man
would ever say that to me
well it's about when
it's about when you're confront when
your woman confronts you with something
she's challenging your
kingdom she's challenging your
masculinity
big time she's saying there's something
to go with
you're gonna have to deal with that yeah
you're not married not married
no lucky ladies uh i just started seeing
someone recently yeah
it's been uh nice man well look forward
to all this oh yeah
you know what's so awesome though once
um she signs out that you're the guy and
you're conducting yourself with the guy
and
and you move in and she moves and that
[ __ ] change she start moving her [ __ ]
around and moving this and the house
gonna look like this
and that's it it's the rap it's over
getting ready to get married boys you
don't think so either you think i'm
gonna get this
let me keep getting the next thing you
know you don't want nobody else to get
it
the more you get it unless you want
anybody else to get it yeah some weird i
don't know why god made us like that
you should think well i already had it a
hundred times i don't want it no more
the more you get it the more you want to
keep it
wow you know that's how life prepares us
for love i guess i don't know wow a lot
of people think like this i'm gonna get
i'm gonna beat love i'm gonna
get all these [ __ ] married and get
them you know what
you've met a ton of guys yeah
billionaires
celebrities you've met the biggest you
know influencers in the world
right over the last 30 40 years i'm
curious
is there a man that you know today or in
the past
who's maybe passed away who feels so
much love in his heart
and feels like he made it without having
a great partner
like can he do it alone and just sleep
with a bunch of girls
you know take what he wants to do he's
that guy can he be that guy and still be
like peaceful and love in his heart or
is he unfulfilled
dig right my experience good question my
experience i gotta
did a lot of stuff women stuff i'm not
proud of like um
the more women you um
you know you would think the more women
you have the more um
more crowning achievements you will
receive from people or whatever the
situation to play a world
but the more women you the more women
you be with the more
you feel like you've been taking parts
away from you
the whole is getting bigger yeah it
feels like you're dying the more you
they take it from you you feel like
you're being taken you're being torn
apart you're feeling empty you're
feeling dark you feel
you don't feel good about yourself wow
you're just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] all these people you got
nothing from them but a [ __ ] [ __ ]
know and what did you get from that
feeling why did you want to have this
and what's the cause of
having that feeling nobody had no you
know maybe three people had babies
but it was like come to be what was the
purpose of that field i don't feel that
way no more that i don't move like that
around
what was the purpose of me to be that
way what did i get out of it no one got
any babies we got some diseases
we you know i mean um nobody got any
love from that
and what that perceived this love what
was that i tell my way was that all
about
you think i would meet all these people
in the afterlife and stuff what's the
afterlife what about the people that
watch me fight would i ever see them
again all of them
um collectively does if all this stuff
go back where
do we all go where what's like the
what you what you're thinking right now
well what am i talking about that
feeling that energy where did that go
when we die
like you're not even talking about that
you're talking to you hear yeah where
did that go when we died i can't die
where does it go i'm just thinking did
they just black out like you pull out a
plug socket what happens with that
it goes back into the circulation but
imagine if it go into a bug or a rock or
a tree
and we become that yeah i'm not sure how
reincarnation works
you know do you come back as another
human being what
you know and why what person you come
back as
i was telling my wife my wife hates bugs
yeah every now and then bug gets in the
house and she freaks out right
i said listen that's probably your
grandmother coming back and
reincarnation she wants to see you so
bad as soon as you have
a [ __ ] squatter wow you know
stuff like that you know i think these
are the people that we love absolutely
and we see them and we hate them so bad
they say mike look it's me but they just
so [ __ ] up
i'm back i thought i was dead hey mike
it's me i kill him
[Laughter]
i know man i've i have a new practice
any bugs
don't kill anything i bring him outside
because my wife is the same she's like
get the spider out of here
yeah i'm like i'm not killing nothing
i've done that right there i'm like
you're gonna kill you kill i'm going to
kill
anything that might be my new policy
when do you feel the most loved mike
when i feel the most loved when do you
feel the most love in your heart
you know when when i'm around watching
youtube
and i hear my kids running around and my
wife comes up and down after feeding the
kids maybe come from work and i'll come
upstairs
and get in the shower may sit on the bed
or sit on her
cheer electric [ __ ] put selective vibes
to a body
and they say i'm very happy everybody's
in the house all my kids are here
and that's when i'm the most loved wow
we're all together
all my oldest kids the youngest all from
school from home and all back together
in the same house i feel
wasn't loved at all wow that's awesome
why do you think that that
experience makes you feel the most loved
and not something else
because everything that i love is um i
feel secured
i feel like listen this is the fourth
sense of security i feel i can protect
them right now i can't
do nothing someone come in there and do
something somebody can come in and kill
us
with a bad forget a gun right but just
the fact i think
that they're safe now mm-hmm because
they're with me
i think they [ __ ] safe because
they're with me
isn't that sick and i know that's
[ __ ] but it just makes me feel it
feels good yeah it makes you feel loved
they're growing it's an interesting
breakdown of that mike
you took it all the way through i love
them so much i don't want them to ever
and i see i say they never experienced
anything i experienced
the kind of people in the things i've
been in prison and
got bad records and stuff they're very
clean kids they got good stuff
good beginning and we got all the [ __ ]
with them you know
my brother i don't know how much time
you guys have i'm i'm just asking some
questions but
when i was um how old was i i was eight
years old my brother went to prison for
selling drugs
so when i was eight until 12 we would
drive
uh you know a couple hours on the
weekends like [ __ ] huh
it was crazy man yeah they they would
drive the weekend you know take like an
hour to get through the security every
time and then i'd sit in this you know
big room with all the convicts and my
brother and
i was eight years old until 12 and i
remember just hearing these stories
about prison that blew my mind as an
eight-year-old nine-year-old just like
what happened
i'm curious what was the biggest thing
you learned about yourself
from from being in jail um what i
learned from jail
this is what i learned from you which is
going to be a trip that there's [ __ ]
beautiful people in this world
beautiful yeah there are there were so
many nice people
there so many beautiful people in this
world they just had hard luck of bad
times and stuff just beautiful people
and they may be killers yeah they've
done some really horrific [ __ ] shot
people did some stuff
drug deals and bad stuff but um they
have a human quality about them they're
kind you're saying that
you have a different look we have a
different perspective of a drug dealer
we looking for the drugs but he has some
guns he's coming with his back
and a bunch of guys got their guns ready
for people for action to come and they
come across big bad
sadistic people but that's not what it
is these are people on hard times
yeah and nobody government's not doing
nothing they're not getting given a
welfare album anymore
you know this is the company if you're
not doing well if you don't make it [ __ ]
you that's the country we live in
i know you don't know what it likes to
hear but if you're not doing good you
don't have a good family you don't got a
good education
you don't have good working skills
you're not a big strong buck [ __ ] you
you come back from the army you
paralyzed you got shot up
[ __ ] you you're old
you can't work handing out [ __ ] you you
immigrate
don't get no skills how your girlfriend
look how your wife look they're
beautiful
can i [ __ ] up no i can't [ __ ] you
yeah but people there are some i've been
up to lancaster to the
maximum security prison up there and
done some workshops and
i did a workshop for five hours the
former nfl guy uh steve weatherford i
don't know if you
know steve punter yeah we played
together in jacksonville there you go
yeah good buddy of mine so we went up
there
i took a few guys and there was about a
room of 25
murderers right that all murdered or
they were like
on the scene when it happened and they
got in there for life whatever right
and they were someone like the most
lovely kind
men now they've been in there they've
been doing the work they've been working
on themselves transforming you know
forgiving themselves
they've been in the work for years
decades
but there's some lovely people
if you're willing to train to do the
work yeah i know that but listen how do
they get how do they how do they how do
these beautiful people that we're
talking about how do they get a good
break when they come out there they got
this [ __ ]
um stripes on their back they wouldn't
read your portfolio they said this
prison [ __ ]
you what you got highly some of these
guys got the highest form of education
from ivy league schools
online in prison they can't get a job
that's true they got ivy league stuff
a guy stanford from there yeah yeah ivy
league stuff
man these guys were geniuses they just
took they went the wrong direction these
guys are geniuses these guys are
brainiacs
the reason why we can't have um radios
and stuff in prison we use because one
of these little crazy
intelligent baskets are turning into a a
phone where they can hear what in the um
office you know what i mean so that's
why we can't hear
you we can't have um the things no more
the walkmans no more the radio because
these guys turning into
devices where they're hearing the
wardens often when they're gonna send
the people up for searches and
lockdowns and all that stuff these guys
are geniuses you can't believe it
they're like einstein they're in there
for murder
drugs drugs these guys are so smart that
all blow your mind man
it's wild i'm curious every state that
the
school requirements have for college you
know institutions and they pass them
with flying colors like they were
cheating
you think they're cheating that scores
that they get
wow it's wild man i'm curious
hypothetically
let's let's say you could pick the day
you get to die
how old would you want to be if you
could say okay i can choose any day
any year would you want to be a hundred
and two hundred years old like
how old would you like to live until i
wouldn't live
long because i wouldn't want to see my
children die
wow okay i wouldn't live long at all
wow that would kill me if i you know see
him growing old i lost the door that
four but imagine that
me with the relationship i had with my
children now you know i would probably
handle it but i wouldn't want to deal
with it i wouldn't want to see this i
would want to die
a lot earlier right well say you got to
say it's your last day and your family
was still alive yeah
and you died say it was 100 and your
family was still alive right
what do you think you would want people
to say about you in 50 years from now
if that was when you died what would you
want people to say about you at your
funeral or just
in life after you pass i don't know i
thought my kids said my daddy took care
of us
oh yeah that's more important my dad you
know the other people
gonna have their opinion their
individuals yeah whatever it is you know
and that's doesn't bother me it's for my
children because i've always been [ __ ]
up in that department
yeah you know my children have to come
visit me and my brother they always have
to see me in prison all the time and
everything
i do went to that part of my life my
kids always got to come to do the glass
gotta take
all my kids through the ah i was [ __ ]
the worst right yeah
well that's the that's cool man that's a
good question
i'm always asking i'm always asking
myself this stuff you know
that's what we are as people we want
people to think something about us
that's our ego we want to think we want
i'm telling people legals are so
[ __ ] big they they want to be they're
mad they can't be at their own funeral
they want to see who
came [ __ ] i think i would i
think i would want something similar
which is like
i i would want people to know that i
really cared about humanity and i i had
a big heart and i wanted to help people
as much as i could
um and just that i was a kind human
being
yeah yeah absolutely i tried my best to
do as good as i could to help people
you know and then you have to deal with
this your best wasn't good enough oh man
imagine that whatever well you're dead
then anyway so you don't have to hear it
anymore
but listen who how do we know maybe
maybe death is another form of life that
we go to
another part of life you know how could
i you know how could life be glorious
and death not be glorious
you can't have death if you don't have
life you walk through the hall and do it
all over again no doubt about it
but i say to myself about that too i
said listen is this an illusion people
are born every second
how what is the big deal why would i why
would god need me to come back he gets
somebody
other people keep they keep coming why
do we need my energy back anymore
we already dealt with your energy we're
doing some new [ __ ]
you died [ __ ] let's see what's
going on we want to talk to you about
you
we may bring you up in some [ __ ]
history class of [ __ ]
[ __ ] work okay well i think that i think
that's a part of our ego believing that
we're gonna continue to live and we're
gonna be reincarnated
no you're finished [ __ ] you had
your turn come on
yeah you know it's possible but
you think about like your question mike
of alexander the great yes
and the thousands of followers hundreds
of thousands of followers he had
and you think about everybody knows
alexander the great's name but they
don't know
joe shmoe yes from there and
the case is still that way there are
a handful of individuals in the grand
scheme
of civilizations that leave a mark that
perpetuates on and on
and so what you might think is why does
the universe want me to why does spirit
why does god want me
to come back or need me to come back
and it's because you carry with you this
knowledge
that you spread that like a virus
a flow of water over humanity may touch
and affect and
inspire others to dream and think in
this way
you know and that's why you come back
because for the souls that are here for
maybe the first time
need to hear this type of stuff because
it takes a lot to wake up in this day
and age
of technology you know hyper
accessibility and comparison everything
judgment insecurities everything yeah so
tell me this right
how does somebody that lived in the
stone age connect with somebody that
lived
right today they died so he died during
the stone age now somebody said do they
intertwine with them the energy
intertwined with another
hey you're my cousin from 10 million
years ago did we find things out do we
receive knowledge for my death
yeah because in our dna it's all
it's all encrypted and coded
into our dna into our cells
all of this ancient knowledge from who
we are for my
um brief um
you know my for my brief investigation
about the toad and all this stuff
and the universe is um
it's just hard to believe that so many
people are born and what happens to
all these people and like you say say a
man say a chinese emperor at one time he
lead he led billions of people
and they and those billions of people
accomplish great things
the great wall of china and all the
great temple all this stuff right where
are their names
where are their names gone
that's a crime they everyone every
million of their names should be
mentioned
that's when they found the territoric
soldiers they had thousands of them but
it was just what
they had too many of them but they put
their names on every one of them with
different characters
different soldiers and they put their
names on them that's cool
and that's the closest that it ever came
down when the whole crew got the
um recognition wow from china
when he made it he made a he made it
made the clay statue of everyone in the
lifestyle
of every one of his soldiers wow and the
soldiers horses and stuff and the guns
and all this stuff
well well in that
same token of
the what did you say mike the actions
of us all of one of us the conduct of
one
faith of us all yes so in the same
vein the conduct of one alexander the
great
yeah is the fate of his entire
community his entire tribe exactly you
know so
he is the embodiment of all of those
people
it's true he represents it right nobody
ever went that far before nobody ever
went that far everyone's been crazy
you didn't imagine marching for 10 years
imagine 10 years just keep going
not ever thinking about home well you
think about home but you never know when
you're coming back
everybody had to they went mutiny on
them when they got to india they said
man we're not going home we've been gone
for ten years
we lost a bunch of people we got
children about other women from other
tribes that's in our group now you know
yeah it's just
whoo that's crazy yeah
[ __ ] bro louis what do you have going on
these days man what are you doing right
now you're writing any new books
i'm working on a new book that i'm just
started writing it's about
eliminating self-doubt nice i think
self-doubt
is the killer of dreams and i think it
holds us back from everything when we
doubt
ourselves listen why do we have doubts
we human beings are the only species
that make doubt up when it's not there
isn't it crazy that's wild it's crazy
that's what i'm going to be writing
about yes how do we overcome that
self-doubt
that keeps us back and it doesn't matter
you know i've you've probably seen some
talented athletes over the years who
maybe they were more talented than you
or something i don't know
um and you were like but they didn't
believe in themselves
and you had enough energy to put
yourself out there and believe
i met a lot of guys maybe you did on the
football field i was not the best
athlete but
absolutely i made it past a lot of the
guys that i played with and i was
always like man you're so talented
you're a mutant you're a freak of nature
but when it comes to the game you get
scared and i
didn't understand it yeah i never
understood it yeah and
the thing is it doesn't matter if you're
the baddest person in the world
and if everyone believes in you and says
you're the greatest you can achieve it
all
if you don't believe you'll never do
anything this is that's so interesting
this is something i always wanted to
find out
like i have some sparring guy partners
people that ask and when i'm supposed
i'm vicious i'm like that limit i know
you cold break your jerry i
and there's some guys in there that kick
my ass right
and you're like what the [ __ ] but you
put them in the ring put them on they're
nervous you put them some pad
some popcorn there and they [ __ ]
panic won't throw a punch i said yeah
fight him like you fought me no he's
fighting the same way please just gotta
keep going
and they freak out this panic they won't
be [ __ ] i think it's
i think part of it is this is something
i'm gonna be uh
researching and going down i think part
of it is our ego and opinions of other
people we care so much about the
opinions of other people if we
the way we look if we fail if you know
something happens we're not proud
of we're so scared of what our friends
our family the media thinks of us
that it holds us back from actually
being in flow and giving our all
right absolutely that's true too with
other things that in that um
realm yeah there's some guys that don't
got [ __ ] ain't got nothing
talk [ __ ] coffee and this guy got the
world they don't do nothing they're shy
and introverted
they don't think much of themselves and
[ __ ] they're scared to talk to yeah yeah
now why is that now if you talk about
self-doubt you need insecurities
yeah you just get to talk to a girl i
know i would buy one no forget you
take this one i think it's uh yeah the
house people
are i think they reject the fear of
rejection
it's like the opinion of what that
person thinks of you if they don't if
they say no to you
then it means you're not worthy and
um at the core of all of our fears is us
not being enough it's saying i am not
enough
and therefore i'm afraid of putting
myself out there because what if this
person says
you are not enough to me i'm rejecting
you then we get scared
and our ego takes over and we don't want
to be put in that situation
in some cases people killed other people
for saying that absolutely
yeah people freak out and it isn't
interesting isn't it interesting that
you could have um the world
saying you got this you're the greatest
and you not believe in yourself and not
take up
the opportunity and in the reverse you
could have the world against you
and everyone says no there's no way you
can do this there's no chance you're not
good enough
and all it takes is one person to
believe and that's yourself
and you can be against the world but if
you have the belief then you can go and
create
it and so that's what i want to
absolutely this book is about
developing self-belief and eliminating
self-doubt because i think self-doubt is
the killer of dreams
that's awesome i used to have a mentor
needs to say that
confidence applied properly
with superseded genius oh yeah the
genius without confidence isn't going to
do anything
yeah it doesn't matter amazing yeah so
i've got that of uh you should interview
mike for it dude
i'm going to i mean i'm going to yeah
for sure i've got that i've got a
documentary i'm i'm looking to launch
here soon
uh that's about it's called chasing
greatness
it's all about discovering what
greatness is and i'm excited about that
and then
my podcast is called the school of
greatness so we interview people like
mike
who's going to be coming on soon and
it's a telethon
i'm going to say something that um john
kennedy jr said
all right i've known him well before he
died
right and he said this um
i met a lot of great men
but um and all those great men i met i
never met there were no good men
and he said um after meeting all these
great men
i decided i want to be a good man
and that's what i said i said i want to
be a good man
people told me i was great for a long
time
but it didn't give me it you know as i
got older it didn't mean anything to me
you know what i mean and then i realized
that being a good man
is you know it's worth more than being a
great man well great men are not good
men
but most good men could become great man
yeah it's true
so true that's great so true
because that doesn't [ __ ] give you
anything no all of the material
success do
anything for your soul you may get five
minutes
five years of gratification for your
achievements
but it's not going to fill the hole
unless you're at peace with yourself
you are in love with yourself listen um
we're human beings
we're we're you know we're human beings
imagine how
do you think you're a great man how do
you take that
what do you
if someone says that to me i would just
say thank you i'm trying to do my best
every single day i'm learning every day
i'm growing i'm not perfect
and uh i just want to help and serve so
i just try to
absolutely focus on service and i say
thank you i'm just trying to serve as
much
like my my my idiotic i thought of a
great man's man like ghandi a man that
gives up all this money gives everything
to something
but that don't make him a great man
that's this man don't give a [ __ ] about
money
but that don't make him a good man
either you know he's just value he has a
price but his price is not money might
be sex yeah might be liquor might be
drugs
this might be his happiness you know
what i mean
and all happy people are not good people
you know what i mean
yeah you could be doing bad things and
feel happy about it yeah we're happy
people are not good people
that's interesting
good stuff man this is fun guys it's
really good when you see somebody
that's in a bad situation and you try to
make that situation better that's a good
person that's a good person yeah
you don't have to know him or anything
but to make a situation better you know
you could do you could simply smile
yeah you don't have to do a lot to
change someone's energy and make them
feel better you can smile you can
100 say how are you you know yeah it's
just your energy your way of being how
you show up so
there's a lot of homeless people around
l.a yeah you live in l.a i live in west
hollywood downtown
west hollywood there's a lot of people
too yeah yeah and on my side of town in
noho
north hollywood in hollywood but
hollywood they got the functional
homeless people yeah they're still clean
they're still not talking
about cell phones yeah yeah these guys
downtown don't have
nothing they're gonna die there man
yeah it's really bad but you know
i try to acknowledge them at least
that's good
you know i feel like those people are so
beaten down
that if another soul can just
acknowledge their existence that lifts
them up to some extent
just smile and say hey i hope you're
doing well hey man you know god bless
you
good luck to you i don't understand
listen um it's funny you say that um
it was a story about alexander the great
and it was this guy got a genius
i forgot i forgot his name it was a
homeless guy and he never complained he
was always happy and alexander was the
king of greece at something he wanted
he said hey listen i notice you you have
nothing
you're always happy i have everything
what can i do for you
and the guy said this he said for once
if you can please just get out of the
way of the sunflower and get my
hahaha and alexander just couldn't
understand why this guy had nothing but
he was happy
and he had everything he wasn't happy
that was confusing
it's interesting i've been a part of a a
charity called pence the promise where
i'm actually tonight i'm flying to
guatemala
every year i go on a trip uh we go to
guatemala laos and ghana
and build schools interesting it's cool
there i like it there
but we go and build schools i've been
doing it for seven eight years a guy
named adam braun founded it scooter
brawn
uh yeah part of his brother i don't know
if he knows scooter we do
yeah yeah so um i'm going tonight and
every year i go on a trip for about four
days and i see these kids that have
nothing they're in the middle of they're
so [ __ ] happy man
they have nothing they have no schools
they have no they have a hut
but then they get like a little sandwich
and they're just hanging out with their
family
and they're kicking up soccer ball in
the dirt field with
you know you know trees in the middle of
the field and they're
you know they're so happy kicking a rock
around well they don't expect anything
in this country we were taught to expect
things even if we don't work
we expect to have that beautiful girl we
expect that their house we expect to
have that money
someone give us money yeah they give it
to us they're so happy and so when i
come when i'm there for four or five
days and i come back and i
drive through beverly hills to get to
west hollywood and i see it's grotesque
this the material abundance and people
honking in their
400 000 bentleys or whatever and getting
mad and i'm like
these people are so happy with nothing
they've got family they've got laughter
they've got health
and people in beverly hills not everyone
obviously but i see people that are
angry
and i'm frustrated cosmic joke man isn't
it crazy
no this is crazy people are so fragile
life is fred
it's hard living life you see people
they say they make a bad mistake think
it's over they may kill himself
life is hard to live yeah by making the
thing with oh god i've never given the
money i'm never going my girl left me
nobody ever let me bow i'm dead
you know it's just people it always
passes though right yeah you've been
through some crap
but you have to go through it some
people can't go through the ring a lot
of pain to go through that pain
a lot of pain deal with that pain then
you have to be willing
to always see the light it's so hard
when you feel like cultivation
suffocating though yeah but it's just
your mind playing tricks
it's all mind-blowing your mind [ __ ]
with your mind
we're so human beings are so drama
filled with movies in our own self
that's it it's the stories we tell you
we listen to [ __ ] [ __ ] it's not even
true when we playing until we got the
emotion to cry
it's cool isn't it it's gone it's cool
it's [ __ ] good man well this is fun
what do you think dude we have a ball in
here this is a great conversation
it's a great i'm excited to have you on
soon and just talk more about this stuff
so
hell yeah dude i don't think people i
mean
i don't think a lot of people know this
side of you maybe they do i only you
i just turned 36. he's still young
where's the dig right
how do you know 31 yeah baby but listen
do you ever think about that like where
the [ __ ] am i going to go when this [ __ ]
is though i know you don't think it's
it's a blackout boom
yeah millionaire is gonna i think about
it every day yeah you do
because it's kind of exciting too be
honest what's next exciting
because you know god didn't make us for
us to blank out do you think god made us
first yesterday hey it's over blank out
we don't exist anymore come on
they're interested the galaxies are so
[ __ ] big
i think sometimes that we're in
somebody's dream
no we're in somebody's system we're guts
with cells we're
we're living inside somebody that's just
so [ __ ] big we can't even spasm it
why not no why not remember in men in
black
at the end when they pull all the way
out and they're just
in this marvel that this giant being is
just flicking that's it
yeah why not who knows i don't know
you know ancient time they said we lived
among giants
yeah you know they see these giant
footprints they can't explain ancient
ten thousand year old footprints that's
like ten foot long and [ __ ] ten foot
wide
giant footprints yeah there's a lot i
mean
it gets weird man and you get it we
can't listen
all that stuff they say it might be true
we don't even know atlantis
yeah i could believe that i could
believe in atlantis there's another land
too called pan yeah yes
it was like fairies and [ __ ] wow yeah
lost civilization peter pan
like the earth spirit
i don't know [ __ ] gets weird this is fun
guys i appreciate you guys you know what
pie is pie is the highest number that
ever
3.14 the pie right that's what it is the
highest number
the highest [ __ ] number imagine i had
pie dollars
over the last few years too much money
yeah so much galaxy
imagine you know the planets the plants
all the planets
all of them um sad and all the mercury
they're like this planet you know inside
of the planets are all
rich um jews and minerals all the
planets have them you know every now and
then you see
um meteorites hitting you up boom you
hear that dust coming it's gold dust and
diamonds all that stuff coming out
yeah and just like this planet has a
bunch of diamonds and minerals and all
the planets have them
and that's what that's and that's why i
think we're trying to get over there
before we could dig those plants to get
all those minerals out of there
yeah we wouldn't be able to get enough
planets you guys have hung out with some
pretty
rich people yeah do you think there are
rich people already living on other
planets
um listen right i don't think that far
is colonizing already they're already
there
listen i believe um bezos has a crib on
mars
if it's true you know i don't even
believe those guys ever really been on
the moon and all that stuff right really
listen are you heading to flat earth
mike no i don't know if i'm heading
there but i'm just saying i don't know
and i know our government lied to us
since the beginning of governments
absolutely no i mean they told us the
story of adam and eve
yeah and we had to believe that let me
tell you the first year
my i always think about the first to me
the first person with my genes that ever
lived
he could have been chinese they could
have been white coming 10 billion years
ago
never know me the first man figure in my
life
if my my existence my bloodline could
have been chinese who knows
yeah you know could have been a [ __ ]
dog a gorilla he never know
for sure who knows we don't know
um why they keep us in this [ __ ]
perpetual state of [ __ ]
fear and dumbness listen but this is
this is the story
when we um when we stop being afraid
we're ready to die
hmm isn't that crazy when we know that's
the paradox
even when you're young we're no longer
afraid you usually die
you know interesting fear keeps us alive
fear is a friend of ours you have some
realization
yeah and then you go
should we wrap this up sure why not
do you guys have a special ending too no
no good to see you thank you
powerful this is awesome it's beautiful
big mike hope to see you again
appreciate you man
thank you beautiful meeting you man mike
amazing episode brother
hey wait where can people find you yeah
tell us uh at lewis howes
l-e-w-i-s-h-o-w-e-s and uh on instagram
or
wherever and then school of greatness
podcast awesome
yeah check it y'all why do you think we
could we um
we put greatness and wealth in the same
category
i don't do that we know most people yeah
yeah yeah you know
i think it's uh too i think they think
of like wealth and success
the reason why for me it wasn't called
school of success because i think that
word is
um i don't know it's just not used that
well it's it's tied around
like money and accomplishments where
greatness for me is not about
money and accomplishments it's about
service it's about how can you use the
sacrifice
yeah it's about how can you use the
gifts and talents that you were given
that you were born with to cultivate
them
and pursue a dream that you have and in
that pursuit
how can you impact the people around you
the maximum number of people for me
that's what we do about homeless people
what do we do about having
homeless hotels imagine a hotel like
vegas like like um the mgm
a 5 000 room hotel imagine something
like that for the homeless
and as they and then as they go in the
hotel they learn how to take care of the
hotel they learn how to handle it
take the people they don't have the um
bellhop they don't have an
administration
they learn all that and then they build
more hotels all over the world for
homeless people to learn how to make
live their lives
i think it's a great concept if they
have the responsibility and want to do
the work and
and and want to show up and work you
know that's the challenge
[ __ ] man well we'll have you on again
and we'll
go deeper on success and greatness i i
think it's awesome man i appreciate it
man appreciate it
appreciate it man all right everybody
that was another awesome
edition of hot boxing yeah check us out
subscribe to our youtube channel right
now hot boxing with mike tyson
also check us out on spotify as well as
itunes
make sure to subscribe we've also got
some merchandise up
dope shirts hoodies we got dad hats
nice check them out hotboxingpodcast.com
i'm evan britton and i'm mike tyson and
we're out of here y'all on
that was fun
[Music]
you